[Music]
thank you guys so much for coming out to
the beach are you excited to go clogging
today yeah
what is plugging plugging is a
combination of jogging and picking up
litter it's Swedish fitness trends that
started about a year and a half ago
I've been plugging for years before it
had a name because I jog on the beach
and was so disturbed by the amount of
trash you're gonna be tempted to pick up
all the trash on the beach there's a lot
of it but then it's no longer plugging
if you're not moving why joggers is
dedicated to stopping the flow of
plastic pollution to the oceans through
science education and adventure so why
plastic in the ocean is such a big
problem is that I can have devastating
impacts on marine life one animals can
get entangled in plastic through
anything with a loop or a line they
literally become strangled the second
thing is that a lot of animals can
mistake plastics or food they can ingest
these particles these particles can
introduce toxins into their bodies and
this can eventually affect you and I who
are at the top of the food chain
like not like a regular dragon trying to
say that you think it's hard but I don't
have sand in my shoes which I'm happy
about
touch a bottle that has a liquid that is
not native to set bottles
[Music]
you're stretching long jockey
- a lot of people wonder why there's so
much plastic in the ocean when most of
us we throw stuff in the garbage can
recycle right well any time you walk
down the street and see am overflowing
garbage down or you see the trash
collectors picking up that garbage can
and dumping it into their collections
and a lot of that stuff escapes a lot of
the small things are escape artists
things like straws and forks and
utensils and then anything that hits the
street eventually markets its way into
the oceans - rains and through storm
drains and wash shacks the work out it's
really a workout you forget you're
supposed to be jogging sometime
already let's count our trash Stuart are
we counting all the straw it's a
speciality yes I had to but because I'm
living each other's two pennies no way
so what can people do to help well first
we had a great example of what bloggers
can do picking up pieces of trash while
jogging or walking with the family
second is aligning our purchasing with
our values so not using sila news
plastics avoiding water bottles and
straws and forks and switching to raise
hopes and the third thing people can do
is getting involved in local action
joining groups like 5 gyres getting
involved in the break free from plastic
movement and help them to drive local
policy change I picked them about 140
pieces I picked up about 95 pieces I
picked up over 100 pieces yeah let's
wash our hands yeah we only plug for
about a half hour and we got so much
trash so much it's crazy like midnight
was super heavy I think it definitely
made me think a lot about pollution the
beach is like this fun place where we go
to like 'hey relax and we don't even
think about the things we leave behind
there go clogging guys go clog did you
work out and save the earth
yeah but really though think twice about
the trash that you leave behind because
sometimes things just don't get picked
up by people
[Music]
you